welcome back to las vegas now when it
comes to real estate the big question
usually comes down to is now a good time
to buy well here to share some insight
from las vegas real estate now the
sponsors of today's segment is harvey
blinkfeld harvey thank you for being
here so glad to be back jillian so this
is the million well we're talking
lottery the billion dollar question
is right now a good time to buy a home
it is i mean uh if you've been a buyer
over the last several years you've been
frustrated um you're competing with cash
buyers were having to pay
over appraised value many times which
meant you had to come in with a lot of
cash or be prepared to come with a lot
of cash
you also the competition was fierce you
know anything went on the market had
multiple offers and so you you got very
frustrated so there's opportunities now
that there weren't available to you as
little as 10 weeks ago the inventory has
tripled we went from 20 little over 2
500 single-family homes to now over 7
500 single-family homes available so
there's opportunities for you if you
were a seller i had a lot of sellers
come to me julie and say hey harp i'd
love to sell my house but i got no place
to go
now you've got choices to make for
yourself and the big concern now might
be the interest rates
and interest rates did go up for a while
but they've recently come down again
and uh john ingram one of my favorite uh
colleagues in the lender his comment is
look you want to marry your home but
just date your interest rate so you can
always change the interest rate later
and when they come down you can
refinance it and also the other concern
for buyers these days is jeez is the
market going to go down
that's the big question is it's going to
go down there's nothing to indicate that
it goes down in any significant way at
all it might bounce around a little bit
but we don't see any major crash or any
downfall in values that's not in the
cards right now so the opportunities are
there you need you don't need as much
cash as needed before there's plenty to
choose from interest rates are up but
they've been coming down too and you can
even buy your interest rate down now
these days and pay a little extra up
front and buy it down so your payments
will be within reason well and you kind
of touched on this but let me ask you i
know a lot of homeowners who decided
they weren't even in the market to sell
their home and they realized the value
was so high and they said i'm just going
to sell to sell because who knows if it
will ever reach that level again
is that the right mindset to have i mean
look when you're talking about your with
the place you live your home uh the only
time you'd be concerned about the value
is when you want to sell or when you
want to buy
in between that it's nice to watch it it
doesn't really matter that much so look
i would say if you really need to move
or you want to move you want to get
bigger smaller closer further something
like that by all means do it buy a home
you can afford and then later on if you
have to refinance and knock that payment
down by all means do it knock the
payment down and what would your advice
be to those first-time homeowners i
think everyone's a little too
intimidated especially when people are
coming in from other states and now you
just feel like the competition is higher
than ever so what would your advice be
to them okay so now is the good news is
you have choices to make and the first
time home buyers it's more of a
challenge the first purchase for any
home buyer is the hardest because you're
writing checks
you've got to write check for down
payment closing costs things of that
nature the checks won't have to be as
big as they would have had been a little
while ago but the second and third
person the purchases after that they're
easy because you're just taking the
money out of your current house and
moving into another there's no checks
being written it's really simple so i
would say the buyers look don't be
afraid if you're renting
remember this when you're renting you're
paying a hundred percent interest
you're getting no value whatsoever out
of renting so that's why i'm so
passionate about convincing people you
need to be a homeowner well harvey thank
you for breaking this all down i think
you're putting a lot of people's minds
at ease and it is an overwhelming market
out there but you're making it easy for
us and thank you for sharing all of your
tips with us and thank you again to las
vegas real estate now for sponsoring the
segment for more information can call
702-203-1165
or visit lv lvrealestatenow.com